♪♪
>> Jason: FINALLY TONIGHT I WANT
TO WISH A HAPPY BELATED
INTERNATIONAL INTERN DAY TO THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE COLLEGE
ASSOCIATES DAVID VEGA AND
CAROLINE LEERY BOTH JOINING ME
NOW.
DAVID, WHERE ARE YOU FROM AND
WHAT'S UP NEXT FOR YOU?
>> HI, FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
HELLO TO MY PARENTS.
I LIVE IN CAMBRIDGE
MASSACHUSETTS AND IN REGARDS TO
THE INTERNSHIP, I'VE MOST
ENJOYED HOW IT'S STRUCTURED.
I LIKE HAVING, YOU KNOW, SEVEN
HOURS YOU PUT YOUR WORK INTO
SOMETHING AND THE LAST HOUR YOU
GET TO SEE ALL OF YOUR EFFORTS
ON SCREEN ON TV.
>> Jason: YOU'VE DONE A GREAT
JOB FROM WHAT I HEAR.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Jason: WHAT ABOUT YOU, WHERE
ARE YOU FROM AND WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO NEXT?
>> I'M FROM CONNECTICUT AND NEXT
UP FOR ME IS BACK TO SCHOOL BACK
TO COLLEGE, I'M STUDYING ABROAD
IN THE FALL AND IN REGARDS TO
THE INTERNSHIP, IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO CHOOSE WHAT I LOVE
MOST, BUT IT'S REALLY COOL BEING
EMERSED INTO THE TV, YOU KNOW,
WORLD AND ESPECIALLY WORKING
WITH A LOVELY INGRAHAM ANGLE
TEAM.
>> Jason: THAT'S GOOD, THAT'S G
DAVE AND CAROLINE THANKS FOR
YOUR HARD WORK GOOD LUCK TO YOU
AND WE CAN'T FORGET THE FORMER
ANGLE'S INTERN GABRIEL WHO N